hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and it finally happened in
the middle of the second major war arc
in mha the mother of all shipping wars
just broke out as himiko toga decided to
confess the truth to deku in the
craziest way possible deku is shocked
ochako took emotional damage oh and some
other stuff happened involving shigaraki
you know like the fate of all of japan
and the entire world is at stake so i
guess i gotta talk about that as well if
you guys enjoy our boku no hero videos
and you want to see more in the future
just leave a quick like and comment it
only takes a second but it really helps
with that youtube algorithm and of
course if you're new to the channel or
maybe you've been watching our videos
but you just haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a quick favor and
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications it might seem like
a little thing to you but subscribing on
youtube is actually a really important
way of supporting the channel directly
and it's totally free you can also hit
me up on twitter and instagram at anime
opera finally this video will contain
boku no hero manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned we start things off with
shigaraki absolutely devastating the ua
grounds with his endlessly multiplying
finger powers somehow this ability looks
both badass and gross at the same time
and it's pretty crazy to see the main ua
building actually being destroyed by
shigaraki like this this really makes me
think that the end of the manga is close
because shigaraki destroying the ua has
some serious final battle vibes the
heroes still can't figure out how
shigaraki is able to use this finger
mutation quirk when his quirks are being
erased by monoma but eventually they
realize that this is not a quirk at all
this is just bodily growth kind of like
hair and nails grow except this is flesh
and it is insanely fast shigeraki
explains that this is all related to the
quirk singularity which was that theory
that ujiko had been pushing for decades
but which was ignored by the heroes and
the rest of society just a quick recap
quirk singularity is the hypothesis that
quirks are getting stronger and stronger
with each generation and this happens
because parents with powerful quirks get
together to produce children with even
more powerful quirks as their own
powerful quirks combine and so on the
problem is that eventually the quirks
will become so strong that it will be
impossible for the human body to control
them because the human body doesn't
evolve nearly as quickly as quirks do
when this occurs overpowered quirks that
go berserk could wreak havoc throughout
the entire world and cause the
extinction of the human race so the
whole point of the procedure that ujico
performed on shigeraki was to force his
body to evolve in a way that would allow
him to control even the most powerful
quirks his very flesh was modified so
that his body could keep pace with all
the new and powerful quirks that he now
holds within his body and one of the
effects of this procedure is shigaraki's
ability to grow his flesh in this insane
way so this is not a quirk it is the
ultimate evolution of the human body
itself after shiguraki's explanation we
see that my wife miroko is thankfully
still alive she lost both of her
prosthetics during shiguraki's attack
but she has multiple spares stashed away
on ua grounds so she replaces them very
quickly her and bakugo regroup as all
the heroes prepare to fight shigaraki
okay horikoshi okay we're cool i was
gonna rage quit mha if my girl was hurt
again but now i guess i can keep reading
the manga and making these videos by the
way during the brief exchange between
miroko and bakugo we saw that they
basically have the same aggressive
stubborn and cocky energy and this
provided us with some brief comedic
relief before we returned to the serious
stuff also i think that i might have a
type because i'm into both miruko and
bakugo's mom i guess bakugo is just
lucky that he's not a girl anyway
mandalay is able to get in touch with
deku and he tells the others that he was
pulled into a portal by togam and is now
at octo island octo island is a tourist
destination that is home to a
world-famous aquarium managed by gang
orca and this island happens to be
located 200 kilometers off the coast of
japan that is obviously a massive
distance from where shiguraki is
currently located and it would take a
long time to cover this distance without
some sort of teleportation quirk and so
deku tells the heroes to warp him back
to ua but unfortunately they can't
monoma is able to copy multiple quirks
at the same time but when he uses them
he can only use one quirk at a time
since he is currently using erasure on
shigaraki he would have to stop that in
order to use warp gate to bring deku to
ua and even if that quirk switch only
took a few seconds that would still be
enough time for shigaraki to use decay
and destroy all of ua instantly or at
least a large chunk of it because i
assume that the whole defense system
thing is still working either way the
heroes can't risk it and they can't
teleport deku if deku is going to get
back to ua he will have to find a way to
do it himself this is a very interesting
turn of events because teleporting a
bunch of villains 200 kilometers off the
coast of japan is actually a great idea
if you want to divide and conquer them
but now that deku got caught up in the
crossfire the plan totally backfired i
mean we can all safely assume that deku
will get to fight shigaraki eventually
because that is the big final showdown
that we are all waiting for but how is
he going to get back to ua is this going
to be the moment when deck unlocks his
final quirk and that quirk will turn out
to be super speed or something along
those lines let me know how you guys
think that deku is going to find his way
back to ua as the heroes at ua prepare
to face shigaraki without deku the focus
of the chapter switches to octo island
the heroes on the island including gang
orca are busy fighting the high-end nomu
who now seem to be even stronger than
the nomu that the heroes had faced in
jakku it's possible that all for one
stuffed them with even more quirks and
made them even stronger in the meantime
and these no more not the heroes only
problem some prison skps are also there
including the notorious villain and bdsm
enjoyer moon fish sirius from the oaky
mariner crew is also there which makes
sense given the setting but it's
especially cool to see her since she
actually started out as an anime only
character however she is now canon to
the manga as well she and tsuyu are
trying to get their bearings and find
deku and ochoko in all the chaos that
ensued after they were warped to octo
island but deku and ochoko have their
own problems to worry about after
speaking to mandalay and the others deku
tells ochoko that he can't be warped to
ua so he has to find his own way back
ochako screams that he has to hurry and
go right away but before deku can do
anything toga shows up and says don't go
deku kun i love you please don't go and
as she is saying this and blushing and
everything she is also swinging her
knife at deku but i mean that doesn't
even surprise me when it comes to toga
what is surprising is the fact that
danger sense isn't activating even
though toga is swinging her knife in
deku's direction and the fourth user's
vestige believes that this is because
toga genuinely loves deku so the threat
is not registering as danger if you guys
saw my last mha video then you know that
i was speculating that something like
this was likely the case toga doesn't
have any ill intentions towards deku but
her way of expressing love is so warped
that it can be dangerous for example she
doesn't seem to realize that attacking
someone she loves or biting someone she
loves is a bad thing that's just how she
shows that she loves them and so her
behavior doesn't trigger danger sense
even though it can in fact be very
dangerous a confused deku is like what
the f toga what do you want from me and
that is when toga pulls yet another
gamer move blushing and smiling while
still clutching her knife toga says that
she wants deku to be her boyfriend as
both ochako and deku look on in
disbelief this crazy chapter comes to an
end but the final page promises that the
emotions are only going to escalate
further in the very next chapter whoa
this is just insane not only has shigak
evolved into some sort of superhuman
that is resistant to the quirk
singularity problem but the shippers are
now absolutely losing their minds deku
is sweating bullets ochako is getting
ready to fight for her man some genius
on twitter is probably mad that it was
toga who confessed to deku instead of
minata and so on man this chapter was so
much fun and just in general the mha
story is out of control right now like
seriously what is deku going to do now
being the kind-hearted hero that he is
how does he fight someone who seems to
genuinely love him and just wants to be
with him like yeah clearly toga has
extremely warped values and her sense of
right and wrong is completely off but
danger sense proves that deep inside she
doesn't have bad intentions like she
genuinely doesn't realize that what she
is doing is wrong she doesn't fully
comprehend the consequences of her
actions so even though she does evil
things someone like deku will not want
to hurt her he will want to help her but
how do you do that while she's swinging
a knife at you while asking you to be
her boyfriend please let me know what
you guys think is going to happen with
this whole toga thing is toga being
genuine here as danger sense seems to
indicate or is she maybe doing all of
this just to keep deku distracted while
shigaraki takes down the heroes knowing
toga i just kind of doubt that this is
all part of all for one's plan since i
think all for one would prefer to have
one for all near him rather than on some
island hundreds of kilometers away but
assuming the toga is being genuine in
all of this how does deku even react
does he try to defeat her in battle does
he try to somehow reason with her i mean
good luck with that does he try to trick
her by saying okay sure i'll be your
boyfriend now help me defeat the
villains baby does ochako just snap and
launch toga into the stratosphere i
really don't know where this is going to
go toga is such an unpredictable
character and that is what makes this
turn of events so much fun i'm honestly
excited to see where this completely
twisted love story goes
in terms of shigaraki what do you guys
think of his new flesh growing powers
and is this something that the heroes
can overcome is it possible for
shigeraki to overuse this power and lose
control of his body or is he perfect now
and so he doesn't have to worry about
any side effects can the heroes keep him
from destroying all of ua before deku
returns are any of the heroes going to
actually die
in this battle don't forget to share
your thoughts down in the comments below
finally how will dekku make it back to
shigaraki i mean it wouldn't be a real
final battle unless shigeraki and deku
go all out against each other but how is
deku going to cover hundreds of
kilometers within a relatively short
period of time is someone gonna help him
is his final quirk going to have some
sort of super speed or teleportation i
can't wait to see what happens next if
you guys enjoyed this video and you want
to see more boku no hero videos here on
the channel just leave a quick like it
only takes a second but it helps a lot
then if you're new to the channel or you
watch our videos but you just haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet remember
that subscribing and hitting that bell
is a very real way of supporting the
channel and it's completely free you can
also hit me up on twitter and instagram
at animeopror i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime uproar patrons
for making videos like this one possible
special thank you to kyle salisbury this
man is an absolute mad lad and a
disciple of lord to ego himself and i
can't forget all of our the one tyr
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including alpha sigma
ingrata algital pate heffa the
red-haired fox hinokami and water the
toasted chi corey mcgowan spidey left
tanel tungsten tarkis big buddhist and
jeremy cummings finally thank you also
to our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only gilgamesh steelers
angel crews alicia octor bonnie parks
joy and garcia fatboy games kaido might
be a duck jessica rabbit jeremy phillips
and alivania if you enjoy our videos and
you feel that they provide value for you
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you